cord later. So, welcome back everyone.
Uh, this is the thing that we have been
doing now for a little bit of time where
our goal is to talk about AI that works,
talk about real code, talk about things
that are going to scale, and also build
reliable systems for different kinds of
use cases. Um, I'm Vibv. I'm one of the
creators of BAML. Uh, but more
importantly, I've been in machine
learning for about 10 years. I've worked
on all sorts of systems from Face ID to
predictive systems at hedge funds all
the way to augmented reality systems
over at Microsoft and unreliability is
the hardest thing to deal with. Uh so we
want to talk about that in different
ways and Dexter. Yep. And I'm I'm Dex.
Um I'm working on a tool called human
layer which again we're not here to
shell anything. We're just here to learn
from each other and build AI that works
and figure out how we can push today's
models to the bleeding edge. But um in
the last year or so, I've talked to
hundreds of founders building agents and
learning what reliability means to them
and what kinds of human in the loop and
all kinds of asynchronous orchestration
and um worked really closely with IBOV
uh for a long time on like what is the
future of agents look like and how can
you build agents where you have a really
high performance ceiling and you're not
locked into kind of the assumptions of
various frameworks and things like that.
So that's that's what that's why I'm
here. That's what I'm passionate about.
Cool. And today's topic is about MCP
texture. Do you want to clue them in on
what we're want to talk about? Yeah. Um,
so the idea is um, we've done a lot of
examples in that video is is one of them
and we've done a couple workshops so far
about um, like tool calling agents in a
world where you want to maintain
complete control over the prompt and the
control flow. Um, but I think one of the
things that has people so excited about
MCP is there's a little bit less. It's
kind of a uniform interface for pulling
additional tools into your system. Um,
and a request we've gotten from a lot of
folks is basically, okay, how do I take
this 12 factor agents methodology and
kind of maybe get to skip some steps or
accelerate my development by not having
to write the tool implement? Like we're
really good. What we care about is like
optimizing the prompt and the structured
output so that when you have a reasoning
trace that's a 100 steps long or
whatever it is that ap the AI can still
reliably select the next tool but once
that tool is selected your code has to
decide what to do with it and that's
both uh incredibly freeing and
incredibly powerful but also puts a
little bit more of the work on you. Um,
and so I had this experience building,
we have a deployment bot that runs in
Slack and we use it to like basically
when a when a dev when a when a branch
is merged, uh, it'll run the dev builds
and stuff and then a human can kind of
at message the bot and say, "Hey,
promote this to production." Uh, that
involves triggering GitHub workflows and
triggering promotion workflows in
Verscell. And it spent we spent way too
much time trying to figure out the exact
API invocations to promote uh a release
in Verscell. And it turned out like the
fastest way to do it was like go into
the Chrome console and like copy the
requests and then paste those into a
model and have it write the code because
of the the point is is like integrating
with external systems is hard and MCP
gives service providers a way to give
users a kind of drop in tool uh set of
tools where all all you have to do is
add this MCP to your system and then you
can expose it to your agent as hey these
are options of the types of JSON you're
allowed to output and then once that
JSON that is output, we can actually
send that to the MCP server. And so the
vendor, whoever's maintaining the
upstream service is providing us with a
toolkit or an SD, it's like SDKs for
agents, right? Where I don't have to
learn how all this stuff works. I just
send the tool call to the MCP server and
that's going to handle talking to the
upstream system or API or whatever it
is. So all that is great, but the
problem is what if we have a thousand
plus MCB tools? What if we had 50,000
MCB tools? What if we have a bazillion
MCB tools? At some point, it's not going
to fit in the context window. At some
point, model performance is going to
drop. At some point, just like we use
databases to save data onto disk and
don't have everything living in memory,
we're going to have to build a system
that can go deal with this because
everything interesting happens at large
scales. And if you have a company with
10 users, you can live in memory. It's
just not that interesting. Probably
there are some companies with 10 users
that are interesting. Um, and today I
want to, but before we get into MCP, I
just want to get a poll from people
really quickly, um, about what it is.
I'm going to save this as a meeting
poll. And I'm just going to run this.
Um, and just two questions. I just want
to get a feel for where people are at,
uh, about MCP, like who uses MCP? What's
people's long-term view on MCP? I just
want to get the feel for where we're at.
And I'm going to try and uh I'll leave
it on for about like 15 more seconds. Um
so try and answer
uh if you can. Um if you're just here to
sit and listen, that's totally okay as
well. But we got almost everyone
answering. Um and I'm going to share uh
my
screen just so we can share the poll
results. Um I think I can if I end it
will share the poll results. All right,
I'm going to end. It's been 45 seconds.
In three, two, one,
done. All right, I'm going to share the
results in the chat. Uh, can you guys
see the results? I assume you can. Um,
it's out of interesting what we see is
we have some folks about um about 30% of
people use MCP currently. 50% of people
aspirationally want to do it.
Surprisingly, 25% of people will never
do it. Um, and then most people seem to
be bullish on MCP. Uh, a few people
don't seem to like it and uh some people
are like not MCP
exactly. Does anyone that is in the camp
of I currently ship with MCP just want
to share what they do with MCP just to
give everyone else a little bit of
context?
Sure. Uh, I can I can hop in. Um, yeah.
So for me, uh, a lot of what I was
doing, I I took over as like head of
engineering and didn't have a product
manager. And so a lot of the work that I
was doing was basically like, hey, I've
got some loose, uh, assumptions of a
ticket or something that needs to be
done. Um, and I'd like to put that into
like linear or something like that. And
so formatting like a PRD or formatting
something that just quickly kind of
outlines what I needed to do. So I
hooked up NCPs with claude um with
claude desktop specifically and then um
would hook those in uh so that I could
kind of just very quickly scaffold
something out. Um so like that's
something um and I've kind of looked at
different ways of of expanding that.
Like I think MCPs are still pretty early
on so it's been a bit tricky to find a
way to like scale that out. So, a lot of
what I've ended up shipping is like web
hookups to MCPs or custom chat clients
because I want to I want to use it on my
phone. I want to use it on the go like
you know like I can't just tied to my
computer. Uh thanks for sharing. Uh Ben,
right? Sure. Yeah. Thanks for sharing
Ben. I think generally that's what I
have seen for MCPS. I know very few
companies, we've talked to a bunch of YC
companies and I know very very few of
them that actually use MCPs in
production except for enduser things to
get scale out. Um, and I think the magic
of like if you're owning if you're
writing code to own the inner agent
loop, MCP just becomes another layer of
SDK. I think the real magic I was
talking about this on LinkedIn with a
couple folks this week and like the real
magic of MCP is like if you're not
writing code or you don't know how to
write code but you just want to drop a
bunch of integrations into a chatbot
that you already use like claw desktop
or cursor or something like that that's
where it really shines.
Yeah, I agree. And I think but if you're
doing it like for what I've seen it
struggle with is I think the problem
that a lot of people have. So before we
get into this, let's do a whiteboard
really fast like sort of exactly what is
MCP at least from our perspective and
how do we distill it down into the same
systems that we've been used to. So we
do this a lot where like we think of
LLMs as just functions. Functions take
in input parameters and they return a
data type. Let's break down what an MCP
is from a very core principles and then
we can go back and think about the
implementation details of what the exact
implementation spec of what the current
proposal for what MCP is and how that
ends up panning out. Um, and we'll try
and keep this fairly high level. So, let
me open this really fast
slide and I will open the
whiteboard. Um, I'm starting to draw it
up. Yeah.
And I will screen share my whole screen.
So once again, um, if we do see an API
key, try not to copy it.
Um, all right. I think we we are live.
All right. All right. Join the room.
Cool. So MCP servers are just they're
responsible for two things. They expose
two special APIs on top of a standard
what you could imagine as a REST
service. It has one API called list
tools and it has another API called call
tools. That is it. There's nothing else
magical about
MCP. Fundamentally, it's you can view it
effectively as a rest API that has two
special things. And it and like Dexter
wrote tool baked in. It kind of has it
kind of can be. Uh just to challenge
that
Dexter, there's nothing that says I
can't just like put like a database
here,
where I'm loading my tools from. It's
true. Yeah, I I think most
implementations have kind of a static
schema, but but um yeah, technically
every time you call this list tools
endpoint, it could
and every time you call tool, it could
at some point return a say a 404 on a
tool not found. And that is very okay
for the spec of what an MCP has. The
problem that I think a lot of people run
into is when they list out tools, they
do the most simplistic thing. They take
these tools and pass it into the LM and
that works until it doesn't because at
some point if we believe MCP is the
future and I'm I I'll share my personal
view on all that at the end. Uh so it's
not biased in any way. Um the idea is
actually like before you basically
before you send your prompt to the
agent, you would spin up every MCP
server in scope for that query,
everything that's installed, pull all
the tools out and then say like, hey,
here's the user's prompt and here's all
the tools you can call. Exactly. That's
a traditional thing out there. And then
the model will pick a tool call, which
is in our world that we all know is
return a data model. And then we'll call
that data model and then pass it back to
the MCP server.
live
live.
Awesome. So when we are doing this um
the problem with this is a lot of people
call that authorization and all these
security things we have to deal with.
Let's just ignore all that. Let's just
assume at some point we'll be able to
pass in beer tokens of various
permissions authored correctly and we'll
solve all that problem. I don't want to
go into that because that's just a spec
design problem. Um you're talking about
the O questions in the chat. Yeah, I'm
just going to ignore that for now
because I think there's more interesting
problems at hand because fundamentally I
think the first question we should ask
is is it useful to have a system that
returns to us a list of tools? Probably.
Is it useful to have something
standardized that does that? Probably.
Just like it's super useful to websites
for websites to all agree semantically
on a robots.txt file and we all scraper
companies just agree that we're not
going to go scrape robots. We'll scrape
according to robots.txt. txt. It's not
or a website can expose a open API open
API spec that says, "Hey, here's the
methods on this API and here's how you
authenticate to them." Exactly. So,
another equivalent to an MCP equivalent
could just be something that says every
time I go to like uh my
website. It exposes an open API spec
that describes all the ai stuff that is
available to an agent. And there was
another company that was doing this.
They called it like / aagents.j JSON or
something. Yeah. And it was an altern I
think it was almost like an alternative
to MCP and I think now they're just
going all in on MCP just because that's
kind of what's what's become the
standard. It basically is. But like
fundamentally like does this specific
implementation detail where you put it
on a server and everything make sense?
Maybe, but probably not in the sense of
like generality. Like we probably don't
need to require a microser as a bakedin
design concept. But the idea that we
want to list tools makes sense. The idea
that we want to be able to call those
tools dynamically makes sense. So let's
talk about what we could do in the world
of a thousand tools. For those of you
that were here for our very first
episode, classification with a thousand
plus categories, you might find this to
be very very similar. Um, and for those
of you that haven't, I'm going to run
through it very quickly, but you should
watch that full video to get the whole
concept of it so we don't have to spend
too much time on repeating the same
thing because that video goes into much
more detail. I'm going to delete the
word MCP and I'm just going to say I
have a list of tools because what I
fundamentally have is I have a bunch of
tools and I want to go
from one tool or like I want to imagine
each of these are a bucket of like a
hundred tools. What I really
Do do you want to quickly just pull up
the JSON file of like basically we're
not using the MCP servers and um we just
have that like tools.json show people
what it looks like tools.json.
So this is we took there's a there's an
MCP registry called Smithery and so they
have thousands of MCP servers and so
what we did was we b queried the list of
servers and then for each server we
pulled off all of the tools that server
exposes. Right? So now we have like I
think this is like 10,000 something
tools in here or something stupid. It's
like an absurd amount of tools. An agent
should not be able to handle this. So
we're just going to talk about this and
we're going to talk about if we have
these 10,000 tools all from different
servers. How do we go down this? Well,
we need some function. I don't know why
mine is black. What is wrong with
this? I don't understand opacity. Okay.
We need some function that is going to
take us down from a thousand
tools to less. Let's say like whatever
tools we think the model can handle. If
it can handle something like let's
assume we're using GD40. So we can
handle a 100 tools. A model is going to
be pretty good at picking a 100
tools. So Dexter is writing the function
signature given a user query and given a
list of tools which we can just call it
a list of tool. Yeah, exactly.
We're going to return down another list
of tools. That's all we need to go write
out. I'm going to write one thing in
there. There we go. So, this is the goal
for step one. And I'll just call it I
put in query string because this is the
most common in these like raggy type
like retrieval things of like what was
the user's query, but it's actually like
whatever parameters would help our
deterministic code or whatever is inside
this function, which could be more
nondeterministic stuff down the line. It
could be a checkbox in my UI where the
user has explicitly checked off Slack.
It could be a checkbox where they've
explicitly checked off notion or in
addition to the string that comes into
here. Right? So, it's about tying the
system together. But fundamentally, I
just need a function that says given
some query object and a list of tools,
pick a smaller list of tools. Um, and I
can do this could be a random function.
It doesn't matter. That's the point. I
just need something that can go from a
lot to a smaller amount, right? You
could the simplest one would just be
like return tools sub like return the
first 50 tools. Exactly. And a more
complex one is we can use embeddings to
go and pick these tools. And we'll talk
about um how that ends up looking. And
then eventually what I want is now given
this query I want to pick the right
tool. And we all know how to do this as
well which is we have the model go ahead
and say given the user query go pick the
right tool. And that's a simple
prompting problem. Once we have this
calling the tool, it just becomes a
matter of wiring up the right APIs or
calling the right function along the
way. So we don't have to think about
this too much and then we're basically
done. And the real magic here is being
able to have what we call these probes
across the way where we want to be we
want to have probes in two different
sections of the system. We have these
probes over here that
says did the did my system that narrows
a tool narrow to at least one of the
right tools that I need? That's question
number one.
If it did, I'm good. I don't need to
change this part of the system. Then the
next question I ask is now given this
narrower set of tools, did the model
pick the right set of
tools. That's another question I can go
ask. And for both of these systems, I
just ask a simple yes no question. Based
on which one is wrong, I update that
part of the system. And do we want to
just for simplicity assume that the
model's only picking one tool at a time
for now? I know we can support multiple
but yeah for now we can assume that if
we want to support multiple remember we
just use a list you just change the
system to a list and then we kind of
solve the problem
automatically. So now we'll actually go
write the code be before I go into
that. Do people understand does anyone
have follow-up questions on exactly what
MCP is and what we need to be able to do
if we have a thousand plus tools to be
able to leverage that in our
system. I'll pause for like two seconds
and you guys have plenty of time to ask.
This is meant to be interactive because
Dexter and I talk about this stuff all
the time, but if you have questions like
this is the easiest way to get a
real-time answer.
I I have a question I'd like to ask if
that's okay. Yeah. Uh so I just like to
hear if generally this is something we
have people deciding which tool to use
or we basically want to set up LLM so
that they automate it all. So it's like
I'm wondering what the scaling procedure
is like. Is it just all synthetic or do
we have someone actually in a meeting
hashing it out with like domain experts?
Well, that depends on your use case. If
you're in the legal world, you might
want to have some lawyers actually look
and see if the right tools were selected
for each of these use cases. Like, hey,
did the LM were the right narrowed set
of tools selected? Where is the right
tool selected from the smaller set of
tools? Like if I have like tools as much
as like load data from some judicial
record versus like send a message on
Slack like any human can probably look
at say if the query what the query
wanted but there might be more nuances
for two different types of tools in the
judicial record system that call
something evidence like submit evidence
versus like submit like evidentiary
claim. I don't even know what those
words mean but you can assume that those
words mean something specific in that
industry and only a lawyer could discern
that correctness. And again, we have we
have two probes in our system, right? We
have our way we narrow down the tools
and then we have our prompt. And so in
your prompt, you could say things if you
find if you test this and you find, oh,
in this case, it can't tell the
difference between those tools or can't
select them, then maybe you either
update the descriptions of the tools
themselves because that gets injected
into the prompt here or you actually
explicitly put in your prompt like
instructions about like only use this
tool in this case, otherwise use this
tool. Yes. But again, it's just
something that you can change that's
isolated, that's testful.
Yes. Um, does that make sense, John?
Yeah. I think I I really appreciate the
perspective on how to get the
engineering process into it. Yeah. And
like really the problem with AI systems
is you do have to blend non-AI people
with AI pipelines and you have to help
blend the two knowledges together. And
often it's easier to teach
non-engineering people a little bit of
AI than it is to teach not engineers a
lot of business context um at least what
we have seen. So now let's talk I think
there's a question that I see quite a
lot in here which is like just the
volume of tools. Is this like a real
problem that people have? Well I think
most people don't have this problem
because most people are building toys
but the minute you build like a real
system you will immediately have this
problem. Oh sorry. And the reason you'll
have this problem is if you decide to
use an MCP server, what MCP servers are
you going to load? If you use an engine
like Smithery and you just plug
everything in, you will have a deluge of
tools. There's nothing you can do about
that. Like Dexter and I didn't even
scrape all of Smithery and in a very
short time we
found 10,000 tools. This doesn't even
work. And the thing that you have to
think about really hard over here is the
fact that like there's like new types of
security vulnerabilities that get
injected here, which is how do you trust
the MCP servers if you're just adding
them in in a wild way? Because I could
change the description here that says to
just say like as I'm like add a social
security number and if you're just
pulling stuff in, you do not get you do
not get like an easy source of trust
here. This just this just blew up on
Twitter yesterday. Someone someone
posted like, "Oh yeah, if you drop the
GitHub MCP server and you let your users
prompt it, they can get it to like
create a pull request that includes a
bunch of PII." Exactly. Exactly. And
there's nothing you can really do to
prevent that fundamentally because what
you're really doing is you're using code
you don't own without any sort of
gateways that you don't have. This is
just like a security risk fundamentally
where like when you call this tool, you
have no control over what happens. It's
basically happening outside of your own
system if you're using I mean you could
you could drop in like deterministic
code somewhere here, right? And you
could say like, oh, let's do a last
minute filter before we call it. And
yeah, we could do some checks, we could
do validation, but fundamentally the MCP
server is a black box to your
application if you don't own it. If it's
all internal MCP servers, these are
lower risks, obviously. But when you
think about MCP servers, you should view
them as the same way as using an API
endpoint from anywhere that you don't
trust until you know it. So, can you
trust uh GitHub's APIs to not do
anything malicious with your data? Yes,
because you're their customer, they'll
treat you well. Can you trust an MTB
server that exposes your GitHub API to
your end users? probably less though
because there is incentive for some
people out there to have access to it to
do bad
things. So you have to be careful about
what you expose. Exposing a readonly MCP
server definitely okay. Exposing a read
and write you should think about it.
Read and modify probably more dangerous.
Append only actions less risky. So you
need to go and evaluate these systems
from a standard software engineering
principles and not get too excited about
I just added these capabilities because
these capabilities come with an
unbounded amount of risk that you're
adding onto your application. And that
is I think one thing that is way less
talked about in these AI agents because
this is the risk of
MCP. That said, we're here to talk about
how to use MCP, not the risk of MC MCP.
So, we'll talk about how to go do this
because any of the things that you do
here doesn't have to be true with just
MCP. You could have this in your own
app. You could have built 50,000 tools
that you trust that your company
exposes. And now you want to give your
agent those
capabilities. Now, many of you have
probably seen me draw this diagram a few
times at this point where I always draw
like oh my god, not an A. How do I draw?
I want to draw with my pencil. Um, I
always draw these weird things where I
draw this
curve. This curve represents a lot of
software. Uh, so I'm going to draw this
how this talks about MCP and
capabilities. Sorry, what's on the x-
axis here? That's what I want to talk
about. What MCP really does is an MCP
server quickly extends your capabilities
that you're able to cover with better
averageness, but it drops your
reliability in any one service because
what you've done by adding MCP is you
basically taken away more
control away from your control flow
system. So you're not writing if
statements, for loops, all these other
systems around there. You're just saying
pick something, go do it.
And that's like saying, I've hired a
hundred different contractors and I will
just let them shuffle tasks around to go
do it. They'll probably go do something,
especially if they're pretty good. But
yeah, the time classical deterministic
software
versus, you know, here's a hund here's
a, you know, a thousand tools and one
call like the god prompt or whatever.
Exactly. Like, hey, you're an agent. You
can solve every single problem for me.
And this here is like a spectrum. And
so, yeah, more tools is like, cool, I'm
going to write less code and I'm going
to hope the LM can figure it out. But
again, that's what we've always found.
That's what 12 factor agents is all
about is like the less deterministic you
have, the less the less deterministic
your software is. And that's kind of
part of it. And there's always
trade-offs there. And you got to find
your sweet spot. And so what we're going
to talk today is like methods of like,
okay, how can we how can we balance and
how can we find a sweet spot where it's
like, okay, I'm still not writing every
line of code like into classic
deterministic software, but I'm also not
just like handing off the keys and
letting the model go yolo it. Exactly.
Cuz like this line we have here
represents classic deterministic
software. It handles that one scenario
really damn well and nothing else. Then
we add some LMS to it and it becomes
slightly wrong side of the curve. it
becomes slightly worse but it starts to
handle a lot more scenarios and then we
add a bunch of MCP and then like it on
average it might perform worse but it
handles way more scenarios than anything
else that we have done beforehand and
like therefore it's better because co we
care about coverage for our unique
application more than we care about
adding everything else and really it
doesn't have to be an eitheror situation
which is where people get stumped it can
easily just become we will write this
deter deterministics offer for this one
control path we have. We'll write an LM
workflow for this other control set of
control paths. And you know what? For
everything else that we're not going to
cover, we're going to toss it in an MTP
and that will address everything. And we
can just use an LLM to decide which of
these paths we're going to send our user
on based on the current journey that
they're
on. And that is an easy way to think
about these hoppers. It's not an either
or. We can really leverage all of them
together along the way. That said, let's
talk about tools and how we use a
thousand plus tools. And there's another
good question there of like, can we
label tools as critical? I'll add a link
after the session. There's uh there's
some new stuff in the spec where you can
annotate the tools, but it's it doesn't
get sent to the LM. It's kind of
directions to the client. Exactly. Um,
so we'll talk about this a little bit.
So, let's talk about again what is these
tools because I tried to go write this
code and I'm I've I've written as much
of it as I could ahead of time because
most of it's just boilerplate code and
we can just walk through it. It's a lot
easier rather than having to talk about
it. Um, so what I want to do is I want
to open this file and I want to look at
what this looks like. So, what is our
agent loop? As the very first part of
it, our agent loop is going to be this.
We are going to have a function. A
function is going to take a state. And
for now, I'm going to do something
really dumb. I'm going to pass in our
state as purely a string. And Dexter
will probably like this, which is I
added some other other tools. Nice. Um,
our prompt is going to be extremely
simple, which is you are an agent with
access to any number of tools. I'm going
to tell it what it has to do. It's going
to answer with one of those tools and
help that user by picking action from
the following. I should this is bad or
the following and then I'm just going to
write the user I'm just going to dump
the state as a part of the user message
along the
way. Now what are these tools that I
have exposed to the model? I have two
specific tools that I'm going to like
hardcode into my system because I know
MCP servers are just not good enough.
The first one I'm going to add is I want
to have the user have two different
types of messages that I have. One is a
request clarification where I literally
just want the I want to show the user a
different type of message that says I
need your help and I might render that
in the UI separately than a respond to
user message because it's just slightly
different UIs and I just want to have
that differentiated and then the actual
message. So that's my human message. But
then I have a second type of tool that
is all my actions and I'm just going to
mark these dynamically defined. So I
will not define them at runtime. I will
only define them. I will not define them
at compile time. All these actions are
only known at runtime. So this is the
difference between um if you want to I'm
just going to send you one other file.
The uh the kind of like calculator tools
that we brought in that. Okay, cool.
What is it called? Uh tool calculator.
So like this would be like like hard
hard code defining your tools. Exactly.
Uh and then passing those to the model.
And so you could do these all by hand,
but the whole point is in MCP we're
going to do this dynamically. We're
going to fetch something at runtime and
then we're going to feed those into the
model as blend as well. Like you can
say, hey, we have what we'll do is we'll
actually send just like we have like
some statically defined tools like human
messages. We can also just add
calculator tools here. Let's give it the
calculator tools while we're at it.
Like we don't have to it's it's we live
in this hybrid world where some tools
are going to be defined dynamically and
some tools are going to be defined
statically and the static tools are in
general going to have more reliability
more systematic guarantees because we
know about them and the deny tools will
have less guarantees and more less
reliability because we won't really tie
to our UI or end process because we
can't by
definition. Um and then we really just
have this function. So I want to talk
about how we'll end up using this
function. So generally I will try and
write this code by hand. So I'll just go
around it about and go do that. So what
we're going to have is we're going to
have a function that's going to do
something. Now in order to load our
tools from dynamically you have to use
something that can go represent the
tools. So we have a thing called type
builder that does that. And for now
let's just assume that we this will
work. I'll talk about how this does.
Yeah, I might even just put a to-do here
like, hey, look, this is where you would
like dynamically launch your MCP server,
call the list tools, and kind of compact
it into your list of things that you're
going to parse. But we just we did that
ahead of time um and just dropped in a
JSON file. That makes sense. Exactly.
And your your company might do that,
too. You might just cache the tools list
thing so you don't have to call it every
single time you go there. Um because
that file, like we said, could be huge.
like getting 10,000 tools could easily
be I don't know how big this file is,
but like we can just see inspect.
Actually, I think it tells me
um it tell me it's 300,000 lines. Um it
is it
is one it's like 11 megabytes of data
and that may not matter but there's a
point at which like the network does
matter and I don't want to send that to
my client on server all the time. I just
want it cached around. So you as a
developer might also make that choice at
some
point. Then what I have is I'm going to
get these tools. I'm going to send it to
my tool options. Then at runtime, I'm
going to say my actions data model. I'm
going to add a property to it called
tools. And I'm going to add my tools
into this
property. Now, how did I pick how did I
go from a thousand tools to a smaller
amount? Well, in this case, I did the
dumbest possible thing, which is I just
picked the first 50 tools. I did nothing
clever at all. Do you want to pull that
into like a narrow tools function just
to be kind of map it back to the to the
whiteboard
narrow tool and like what is the type of
this thing? This is going to be a list
of field
types. Okay, I have to go import things.
This is probably the only reason I did
not do this.
Um, okay. So, I'm just going to go for
now. I'm going to go do this. I'll pass
in a query stir and pass that in. And
what I will do here is this instead of
this will just be
a narrow tools and I will pass in a
query which is empty stir.
But basically the query would be the
input to your do something method.
Right. Exactly. And then specifically
what I'm saying is hey in this scenario
the tool options is going to be a union
of any of these tools that I passed in
to this uh to this thing. So given a
list of 100 tools I am allowed to pick
any one of those. Now I might say I want
to pick multiple of those and I can just
do list or something. And now I'm
allowed to pick a list of these unions,
but I don't have to pick all of them and
it's up to me to decide. So union is
basically you're going to ask the model
pick one structured object and it to be
valid it has to be one of the 50 types
in this union basically. Exactly.
Exactly. Cool. Um and then what I'm
going to go do is I'm going to do the
next part which is I'm going to write my
chat loop. And many of you have probably
seen this chat loop before. Um, it's
very straightforward. We just put a
while loop true. We have a chat object
that represents our current state. And
we're going to just run this and say I'm
going to pick the action based on
whatever the user based use that LM
function. The action will return one of
my static tools which is a human message
type or and if it is a human message
type, I'll print out the message to the
user. I'll add it to my chat thread that
I have going on over here. And then I'll
take the user's message, I append it on,
and I'll run it again. And this is a
really subtle thing going on here. I
think most people are used to seeing a
big JSON structure here with RO user and
all that stuff. This is actually a great
uh illustration of a concept we talk a
lot about in 12actor agents, which is
like you can tell the model what's
happened so far however you want. You do
not have to use the standard OpenAI JSON
messages format. you could just put the
whole thing in a system message or put
the whole thing in a user message um and
let it work from there. And if you look
at how our prompt works, it's just going
to put all that in. Uh I know models are
like specifically tuned on like user
versus assistant and you could still
implement that, but um it's up to you. I
I think this is worth worth calling out
because it's it's subtle. Exactly. Um so
you can see TypeScript or Riot. Um I'll
do TypeScript next time. It's pretty
much the same thing. You can send all
this stuff to chat and I'll convert it
to TypeScript for you. I was on a stand
up today and my my engineers uh keep
asking to rewrite all our Python and
TypeScript. So I I feel you, Andrew. I
apologize that I have to do the sin of
using Python because we're equal
opportunity builders here. I think
there's a there's plenty of plenty of
reason to use Python and TypeScript. I
honestly think that if you're going to
build things in AI, you should just get
good at both. Uh or just learn BAML and
doesn't anyway. I'm I'm joking. I'll
stop. Um, but I think though when I go
down this road is like I've added this
to my tool and for the other action,
what I'll do is the minute I get an MTB
tool, in this case I'm breaking, but I
don't have to break. I could call the
MCP server and then continue onwards. I
want to pause you one more time. Uh,
your battery's about to die. Oh, shoot.
Yes. Um, shouts out to Remo or sorry,
uh, shouts out to, uh, Shia for calling
that out. Any questions so far? Does
this all make sense?
I mean, shouts out to Remo for saying
Python and Typescript, but
yeah, go ahead, Kashall.
Um yeah, I was just wondering like when
you have like multiple uh functions that
are being run within the MCP server, um
is there have you encountered a
situation where you have to figure out
the right order for the functions to run
and how does the LLM do that? You know,
in some cases the order might be
important.
Yeah. Um yeah, I mean I think the LM's
always going to return tools as a list
and so you could call it in the order
that the LM picked. You can also just
constrain the ln. This prompt that we
have here is constraining it to only do
one action at a time. Um, but you could
just turn this to a list type and then
it could return multiple. Um, I've seen
some interesting stuff where people have
it call it calls the human message tool
and the other tool and that can be used
like depending on how you prompt it like
the prompt is all the like you have
total control over how you ask the model
to talk and so you could say always
output a human message and the tool
you're calling and then we show it to
the user while the tool's being called.
Um, but yeah, for ordering vib you ever
seen anything where like a model picks
multiple tools and you have to decide
what order to call them in? Well, that
I'm gonna I'm gonna do something silly
here, but it's like look, if you care
about ordering and you just
Yeah, but I'm talking more like in a
situation where um I don't know, it's
just imagine like a subject matter
expertise uh subject matter expert who
doesn't really know much coding and
stuff and they're just using this tool
and um the tool is like asking for like
a bunch of websites that have to like uh
go through different things. So, um
there might be a right flow to do do
those operations in your responsibility
as an app developer to determine your
use case. If you're doing a bunch of
stuff in parallel, you're doing that as
an optimization because you just have
the LM do one thing at a time and go do
that. What you've said is I want to go
do things in parallel. Yeah. Just like
if you're doing you have to deal with
race conditions, data races, and atomic
and non-atomic variables. If you're
writing multi-threading code, that's now
your job as an app developer to take on
that burden away from your users. And
how do you do that? You just do this.
You can just say this depends on these
tools as a part of your mort tools.
Yeah. Or you could even take it out of
the LM's hands and you could have
deterministic code that says like hey
for if there are web search tools in the
payload, run all of those in parallel
before running any of the other tools.
But at the end of the day, the model
calls seven tools. The model is asking
you go do all these things and then send
me back the context window once you've
done all the things. So you basically
get to decide and optimize all of that.
Yeah.
Yes. Does that make sense?
Hello.
You know the first step is you have to
find flights that work and only after
you find the flights do you want those
days right you but if you end up booking
the hotels first but your flights are
you know the days are not aligned that's
kind of a situation you don't want so
how can we like you know have the agent
go through those like steps sequentially
is what I'm trying to figure out that's
as a part of your data model your data
model needs to represent the
sequentialness of control flow if you
want to go do that Or you can just embed
that as baked in knowledge like vector
says which is like if you get search
request regardless of what order the LMS
spits out in like um let me let me
change this really fast just to make it
more clear. Let's say I return an array
of tools right over here. I've now
changed my code to
um yeah
exactly exactly said it really well.
Uh so let's say over here I have an
array. I now have a list of actions and
human messages that come
out. It is now up to me to say that this
thing is now going to be what is this?
Oh shoot. I disabled the generator.
Sorry. Sorry. I'm running a dev version
and I need to stop doing
things. All right. Cool. Um this thing
now is going to be a list of actions.
And what I want to do here is I want to
say for action and actions go do the
same thing that I was saying before. Oh,
okay. But now I can I don't have to do
this. I could first say like actions
equal action like sort
actions and I can say I can sort this
now in this way
uh
instance and I can say all human
messages must be processed first before
any other tool that comes out from the
model. Okay, cool. Thank you. Right? So
I can find this bridge and it's up if if
this is important to my application
security development, I can go do this.
Um but this is really really important
that um as a developer we remember what
is something that we can do versus
something that
a versus something that a model has to
go do. And this doesn't have to be a
sort. I could even filter and I could
remove or I could modify actions. I
could say, "Hey, if one of the actions
is going to be like read bank
transaction, insert another action
before that that says show something to
a user that I'm going to read your bank
statement and like send a human message
to confirm before I go do this." Yes.
And Joe started typing something that I
think is really really clear and like
really important is like the first time
I tried to build a tool calling agent
for me for something that I really
wanted. It was like and I've said I
think I said this last week too is like
it was I was building I had a make file
to build my project and it was like
docker build and run tests and all this
stuff and I I started with just like
here's the make file go build the
project and I gave it access to call
bash bash functions and then I kept
doing things out of order and then I
kept making the prompt bigger and more
complicated and I was like first do this
then do this then do this then do this
and I think one of the points we're
going to make on this show all the time
is that there are certain things that
models are really really good at but
like if you already know the order. I
spent like two hours trying to hack on
this thing and get the prompt perfect.
If you already know what the right order
is, you could have just written those
five make commands in a bash script. You
don't need a model to do that. Exactly.
So now I'm going to go run this code
just to give people a little bit of an
idea of what I've been doing. Um over
here um I'm going to stop screen sharing
for half a second while I load my API
keys.
Port. Okay.
And I'm going to be back to screen
sharing. Okay. So, I've loaded my API
keys and hopefully no one will see them,
but if you do, we'll find out. I I have
I have a couple copies of them if anyone
wants them. Yeah. Um, so let's go run
this thing. And I'm going to do a
really, really simple thing. I'm just
going to call it run do something. And
we'll just see what happens.
UV run
tools tool. Oh, I'm not in the right
folder. That's why.
2025 and CD bonus. What is this?
Workshop
bonus. Clear. Okay. UV runtools.
py. So, I'm going to go send it a bunch
of messages. And this is going to run
some stuff. And the first thing I want
to show people is the message I send is
get pages 1 through three from the
database. So we can I want to spend some
time just reading over this prompt so we
can see what happens. It's the same
prompt that we had before. Um I'm going
to move this over here so we can go see
this which is saying the following. You
are an agent with access to any number
of tools. Answer in JSON with one of
these schemas. And I literally just list
out the tools field like I did over
here. Um, I'm going to show what this
parts tools
does. This thing is going to add a
tools.
Whoops. This thing adds a tool field
which is over here into my action data
model and it lists out all the tool
options that I have. So my tool name is
going to be whatever execute command or
something. It has the command timeout
blah blah blah one read output and a
bunch of other tools. Where are these
coming from? What I did over here is I
simply read the JSON schema and I just
converted to a data model of my choice.
This is the other point. You don't have
to use open API spec. You don't have to
tie yourself down to it. You might find
that hey, the word tool name is fine,
but actually it's going to be way
better to not call it tool name. I just
want to alias it to I want to alias this
to like a function name. Oh, function.
Yeah, exactly. So, we can change this
and now the
LLM will basically now call it function
name. And that's the point. Don't tie
yourself down because different models
will have different behaviors and you
need to be able to change this on the
fly in a really easy way. You likely
want it to be the same thing all the way
down no matter what. Now I did something
very unique which is I actually this is
what I call it for the LLM. What what I
actually call it in my code is like BAML
tool name with dollar signs because I
wanted to find that key and not
accidentally pollute it from all the
other JSON fields that people might
have. Sorry I didn't quite catch the the
the usage of BAML tool key. Can you
Yeah, let me describe that again. Let me
call this let me call a tool really
fast. Let's just call like um add a
we'll do this add a to-do actually. So
we see over here add a to-do over here.
So actually add a to-do to jot to send
Dexter the uh the database
ID and I'll say add a
to-do. Let's just see what this happens.
I have no idea.
Um, I need
it. Oh, and you can see what it actually
did. It actually said right over here,
detailed like due date, priority, and
additional description. Why? Because due
date, priority, and additional
description. It actually pulled it out
from here. I need it by
tomorrow, May
28th, and it's high pri.
Okay. Okay. So, the model didn't select
the tool, but it knew what the tool
needed because it was in the pro.
Exactly. So, it used the request human
clarification tool and then it returned
this tool back for me. And why is BAML
tool name here? Well, that's because
this is a special thing that I added
that I wanted. So, for the sake of the
prompt, I don't want to call it
something special. I just want to call
it function name because it's easier for
the model. for the sake of my code, I do
want to call it something special
because who knows what MCP server is
doing what under the hood and maybe they
have another property called function
name and I don't want to deal with that.
So what I do is I just say for the LM
we'll call it function name but in my
codebase I'll call it BAML tool name so
I can find it very easily and handle it
in a more deterministic way. Does that
make sense Dexter?
Yeah, I got it. Um, I mean, you're still
passing it into the prompt as function
name. Yes.
So, I don't see how it quite solves that
problem, but I get I get the concept
you're trying to get across, which is
like you want to have kind of special
reserve fields or something. Exact. And
like if I want to call if I accidentally
even if I call this to if I call this in
the model, the model is going to get
confused. Like we know this is going to
hurt the model's performance. So I'm
going to do the thing that's going to
help the model the most and just alias
that in field to whatever I want to call
it. And then when when basically and the
idea is like we haven't implemented the
part of the loop that actually goes and
calls that tool yet. And we're probably
not even going to do that today. Um
maybe if we have time at the end but the
idea here is how do we narrow sorry what
I do here is I say tool equals
action model
extra
tools oh and this
is okay cool tool this is going to be in
any type it always will be in any type
there's nothing you can really do about
that um if because you're doing it
dynamically at runtime exactly because
we can't really help that. So, we'll
just type it as a
dict. And now we'll go do this. And now
we can say like tool name
equals
tool.pop. What do I call that field?
Name
key. And now I have the name of the tool
and then
args are just the rest of it.
And I can even say print.
Yeah, let's let's see that. Let's run
it.
Yeah, cool.
Let's run
this. And
um
you're going to have to go get your
prompt again. If you just copy the list
of user messages out of the top, you can
do it. Oh, wait. Oh, wait. Scroll back
down here. Yeah, get
that. And that's the same thing, which
makes sense because LMS aren't fully
uh Where did it
go? Scrolling is hard. I should have
made this a test case.
And the other thing I noticed is that
I'm actually not injecting the AI
messages in here. So it sounds like
there's a bug somewhere in my code. Oh
yeah, right over here. I only print it
out. Yeah, I think cursor deleted your
AI message. That makes sense. But
honestly, now it says right over here,
I'd like to call the tool notion AI
notion API MCP tool. And I just send
these args in. And now I can just pass
that into the MCP parameter, get the
response, add it to my chat object in
whatever form I wanted. it doesn't
really matter. And then continue on with
my
loop. Um I'm going to pause here and
just say, do people have
questions? I think the biggest question
that was in there was um that Joe was
asking was like, okay, how do we do the
embeddings and the narrowing in a like
smart sophisticated way? Yeah. Um and I
think that's actually more interesting
than actually going and calling the
tool. Although I think probably we can
publish an example afterwards of like
hey we brought in the Python MCP client
and actually ripped it like yeah we can
just call the tool or something. We can
go do that too. Um I think you're right.
I think this is probably the most
interesting part. What I would do if I
were here is I actually wouldn't do this
in this way. The thing we've done here
is not bad but really what I would do is
I'd say narrow tools um list tools dev
load
tools. Um, and what I'm going to do is
like tool file path. And then what I'm
going to return is going to be a
uh type builder
object. I'm just going to call this
right over here every single
time. So I'm going to parse the tools.
I'm going to parse tool path. I'm going
to return this. And specifically I'm
going to have is I'm going to pass in a
query into here.
And given a query, I'm going to narrow
the tool. So everything looks everything
should look almost the
this. And now we basically are going to
load the tools on every single chat all
the time and pass that object
in. Now we don't Yeah, let's see how
that works. You think that's going to
work? Well, well, in this case, no,
because I'm still returning narrow tools
is still returning the 50 p tools. Okay.
Um, like there's nothing that's
happening over here. Um, but like we
could use embeddings to solve the right
tools. The problem again that I think a
lot of people run into is the problem
that we run into when we do
classification. Most people make the
mistake of saying that hey, I'm going to
use this embed this description as the
thing that I pass into LM and also the
thing for embeddings. That is a mistake.
Just like in classification, remember
what we did and when we did a
classification doc and I'll pull up that
doc again.
Um, hello. There's the screenshots are
in the repo. Exactly. That's I'll just
pull it up on here.
Uh, because I think that's going to be a
better way to just look at it. And we
look at classification and we look at
this like we did not send the same
description to the prompt as we did for
the embedding system and we should not
do that because different different
models have different behaviors. So the
fact of being able to go ahead and we
can say that hey the description for
this category for the embedding text is
different than the description that goes
into LM to help select the right
category is also true for LLMs. The
description that I use here for this
tool is likely not the best description
for actually passing into an embedding
model. Maybe I take the whole thing over
here and I send that to an embedding
model. Maybe I send the entire server to
an embedding model all at once and all
the tools under one server. It really is
up to me of how I decide that and I
shouldn't be tied down to go doing that
in some other way. So even like this
thing that we wrote over here of like
picking the right tools, this doesn't
actually have to be as simple as like I
have a list of tools already. Go select
that. I could say I have a list of
servers which contains a list of tools
and now go narrow from there. And that
could both narrow the servers down and
the tools down. So it's important that I
maintain that control at all times of
how I go do this. And one sophisticated
manner is chuck everything in embedding.
use the description of the tool to
decide what you do. But what ends up
happening in practice is like when I
read this, this doesn't actually help me
if I use the description alone. You
could easily imagine having this, this
is the same description for git github
and
bitbucket. That is useless to me as a
developer. Um, you might have that. Hey,
I know that you are logged in as a
company that I you have connected to my
organization. and you've connected
GitHub. Well, then it doesn't matter
what big bucket descriptions are. I just
use a boolean switch that isn't anything
fancy to just say I only enable GitHub
servers and I don't enable uh Bitbucket
servers. And you'll hear DR and I say
the same thing over and over again,
which is like there is no oneshot magic
trick. And I think that's what people
when when we saw the poll today, why
everyone was so optimistic about MCP is
it feels like that magic bullet, but
it's not. you're just adding more
software and like whether you want to
use an API or not is up to you. Like we
use REST APIs all the time. We don't all
reinvent GitHub. We just use it and it's
useful. So like yeah, it might make
sense to use someone else's agentic
system. But how you use it, how you plug
it in is very important to your actual
application and like that is application
specific.
Cool. Are we going to do it? Do you I
mean I can write the embedding thing.
What I will do is I will just go to our
previous code and I will copy and paste
it because we already have it. I don't
have to re reinvent the
wheel. Um
but we had this thing up here which is
narrow down
category. It's literally going to be the
exact same
code. Um where did it go? Yeah. Yeah.
And I think while you're doing that,
like the main the main lesson here is
right you can you can do this in a hund
different ways. You can use embeddings.
You can do this like I feel like I don't
know the word for it. Um it's not rag
but it's like basically like passing
chunks of data into an LLM and having it
like decide whether any of them are
relevant. Passing lists of tools and you
can have a really small LLM decide,
okay, cool. These six tools are relevant
and the rest of them are not. And you
might get zero relevant tools on most of
your queries. Um, but again it's a
smaller, more focused prompt. Yeah, let
me go change this code really fast
because in order to go do this, what I
actually have to do is right now what
I'm returning here for every tool is I'm
returning the name of the server and the
tool and then the actual type that is
associated with it. What I actually need
to return now has changed. What I need
to return now is going to be the entire
tool object and the type of the tool.
It's no longer a simple object because I
need that object to be able to do the
embedding to do the embeddings. Yep.
Exactly. So now what I'm going to have
here is I'm going to load the tools. Um
sorry I'll load the tools. The tools
will be did I change the type?
Toolable. I'm going to load the tools.
Tools will be a type of tools and
values. This will be tool
types. And now I have to go down and
write this code.
I will go do this and
this narrow down my tools. So I will
have a bunch of tools. For every tool,
what I will do is I will
uh find the embedding of every uh so
you're going to use the raw JSON from
the MCP server to generate the embedding
text.
Exactly. Is this correct?
I have to do
you don't have you need to grab the
embed function. Yeah. So, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to do
JSON.dumps. I'm just literally going to
dump that into my category
and I won't think too hard about
it. And we're pulling some language from
the last one of we're using in in this
one it's called categories in this one.
In the uh tools one, it should probably
be called tool, but yeah, we'll deal
with that in a second. Um, I'm gonna
rename this to field
numpy. And most of this should just
work. Oh man, look at auto doing our
homework for us, building the uh summary
of key takeaways for us. Yes, define a
prompt with an action that's dynamic.
List out all your tools. like we'll
increase the matches to like I don't
know like
100. And now this is going to go return
this. And now we just use this and we
return a union and we're basically done.
Um and that should basically just work.
Uh text. Okay. Blah blah blah. I don't
need that anymore. Let's run this
sucker. This might take a while because
I want to run embeddings on like 10,000
tools. Um so we'll just see what it
does.
Uh, and I'm not running any of it in
parallel because I didn't do it in
async, which I probably should, but
that's okay. Um, actually, get back to
multipprocessing, dude.
Uh,
openi
async async openi. Okay,
cool. Uh, I want to go do this. Does
input actually expect a list of ins? Um,
I don't know how that's going to work if
I send it multiple. So, let's not try
that.
parallel. How do I do this in
asynciogather? Oh, wait. Asyncio.run
async.io.gather.
I am a little stickler for doing this.
So, I will Oh, I see. I will likely
wait. um and editing SQL
and then if you if you wanted to keep
this as synchronous. Okay,
thanks Deborah.
Async. Okay, cool.
Is this working? Oh, and then I have the
embeddings.
Cool. Uh and then I just wait on these,
I guess.
Um, I don't
actually I'm certain that this will get
fixed at some
point.
Okay. I think this will run. Um, you got
to do async io.run run here or make it
async.
Yeah. And then I will have to do async.
Um, we'll do this. And this is doing
something incredibly dumb where I'm
going to call the embed on every single
call to this. So, I have no idea what
this is going to do. Uh, UV add openai.
um and all this seems to be a little bit
I think repetitive from last time but
that's because like the reason I didn't
describe this is you can go learn about
the nuances there very easily but the
whole point of this is that you don't
have to do everything you can just use
the same principles and build them up to
build more complex systems over time
yeah so you could use embeddings to
narrow this
to narrow this down. Oh, sorry, Dexter.
What were you saying? Oh, sorry. Yeah,
there's a little lag. Um, yeah, you can
use embeddings to narrow this down. You
can use um you can use an LM to narrow
this down. You could use some
deterministic code that does someone
mentioned having full text search.
And I'm doing something really really
dumb over here which
is I am if I can I'm basically just
embedding this each JSON blob completely
independently.
So I'm not even embedding the
description. You probably would want to
do like the name and the description or
something, right? Maybe. I don't know. I
I really don't know. The thing is like
for every tool you probably want a
special way to embed it and that thing
is unique to that tool. And in fact, I
mean, so yeah, and this is the point. I
mean, we'll just keep saying every week
is like the idea is not to get this
perfect in an hour. The idea is to build
a system that gives us lots of points
that we can both test, that we can mock,
that we can probe, that we can tweak so
that we can optimize each part of the
pipeline to the point where we can build
a a system that as always gets the most
out of today's LLMs. And this is this is
sort of the approach that we're seeing
both large enterprises and really hot
startups are using all over the place is
like the 100 MCP tools single prompt or
thousand MCP tools sing single prompt
one that that one just breaks down and
like you could just use less tools to
start but eventually you'll actually
want to be able to have an agent that
can do lots and lots of things and this
is kind of step one in doing that. Yeah.
And more importantly, like the fact of
the matter is the actual embedding text
that you're going to go embed is likely
unique to your unique problem. The way
you embed that tool is specific to you.
And any description you use is likely
going to be specific to you. So even if
you have I mean you could even you could
even pre-process and have an LLM read
the JSON and spit out a really wordy
description that then we go use to make
embeddings out of. Yeah. And then I
think you asked the question remod like
could you not fine-tune a small
classification model I mean you could
that becomes another way to build the
same function that we just built over
here which is narrow categories you can
build a classifier that does that you
could build a random algorithm it's it's
based on your use case and how well you
understand your problem and how well you
understand your problem going back to
the eval episode that we did is like you
should have a test suite that's puts a
hundred things in here and gives you a
score out because until you know that a
certain approach is better or worse than
another one, you're just kind of
shooting in the dark.
Exactly. And then like one of the ways
that you see us doing this right now,
we're just like I hardcoded a simple
prompt into my system. I didn't really
think about it and then I put a
um then I just put a while true loop and
I just kept running and typing just to
see if it behaved correctly. Why did I
add this human uh this uh this uh human
message tool? Well, at this point, I've
built a lot of agents, so I kind of just
know that likely the human message is
not going to have enough clarification.
So, I generally will build this in since
I'm building a CLI interactive system
anyway. So, for a CLI interactive
system, I'm just going to default to
this as like good practice that I've
learned. But that just experience of
building these systems. Three minutes
left. Any last takeaways here um before
we jump to questions? I'm hoping this
will run eventually. I forgot to build
the progress bar. This is why I add the
progress bar. It's so nice. TQDM.
Yeah. Uh but no, really the last
takeaway is just like MCP isn't that
hard. It's just an API that does list a
bunch of tools and let you call that
tool. We already have a bunch of other
ways to go do that as well. So you don't
have to tie yourself to
MCP. Calling an MCP server with a
thousand plus tools is just a matter of
being able to narrow down to small
amount of tools correctly. The rest of
this code is easy software and you can
go look at exactly how we did this. Um,
like how we converted that to a type
spec is really easy. You're just
defining open API specs and converting
it to open API says boolean, you make
that a boolean. Open API says string,
you make that a string. Open API says a
these three enums, you make that an
enum. It's a pretty straightforward data
model conversion. So that part isn't
really interesting. Uh, the only part
that is interesting is giving it a tool
name that then you can go call.
And to recap based on what auto said I
think is really good is like basically
define a prompt with a dynamic action
call list tools optionally narrow those
tools um inject those parse into
structured data and inject them into the
BAML prompt at runtime and then handle
the LM response however you would in any
other agentic system. Exactly. That's
it. It's not that hard. It's very few
lines of code. The lines of code get
messy
when when you start doing fancy things
like narrowing down your categories
using embeddings.
Awesome. We had a lot of great questions
during the show. Uh any other questions?
Either drop them in the chat or put a
hand up or just come off mute. What's
been the best performing embedding
model? Uh and what's been the best
performing embedding you've made so far?
How do you implement it? Um, I don't
think there is a best performing. I
think it's very use case uh specific.
But in general, I think it's just
like as long as you can control the text
and the embedding, it becomes really
easy to tweak it when it picks the wrong
thing. So like I think that's the most
important insight is like look, if the
embedding picked the wrong tool, then
there's no way the LM can pick the right
one because it's not even in your input.
So you just have to be able and the
beauty of this system is if as if you
have to tweak your prompt to change your
embedding, you're
stuck. Like that's a bad place to be.
What you really want to be able to do is
you want to be able to tweak your
embeddings completely orthogonal to
changing your prompts. If they're the
one and the same, then changing one
impacts the other. You want to separ you
want a separation of concerns as much as
possible. Is that Dexter? What about
you? Have you seen models that are
strictly better or worse? Um, I've seen
faster embeddings. Yeah, that's pretty
much it. Embeddings really just aren't
that cool. But like there are ways now
where you can make them fast at least.
Yeah,
I think the model is the least important
part of it. The most interesting part is
the content that you're trying to do
things with, and that's what I would
focus on given how good these models
have gotten already.
Yeah, I I agree. I think the the lever
you want to try tweet like it's always
like do the easiest thing first. Like if
you can get to the performance grade
that you need by changing the text that
goes into the embedding, then why on
earth would you go fine-tune an
embedding model or try to use some fancy
one or something like that? And and to
to that point, if you can't do that
level of accuracy, then you should go
fine-tune an embedding model, but try
the easiest thing first.
Yep. And honestly, I would say even like
try a thousand MCP tools in your prompt
first and like see if that works. Why
even filter like who knows maybe 03 will
just do it and you don't your your use
case is not specific to like cost or
latency in any
way up to 70% great then that was a good
change and that was worth it. But if you
had the embedding filtering and it goes
up by 0.01% 01%. You can even say like
is it really worth the extra code and
the time from our team or do we need to
take a step back and do a different
approach? Yeah. Um Tim asked a great
question. How long does it take to take
a symbol embedding? I think it's just
network dependencies sadly. So like I
would just expect anything will take
anywhere from
like 50 milliseconds probably the
fastest you can do and like a second is
probably the worst case outcome. Um,
what I would do is because embedding
should be cheap is I would just deploy a
small embedding model into your own VPC
and just call it a day. Use like Bedrock
or something else to go hosted, Azure,
whatever you want. Um, and that's
probably the best bang for the buck. Um,
because as we're seeing here, processing
of 10,000 embeddings does take a while.
Uh, it's taking a long time for this to
run and I can't really do anything about
that. I just have to let it run.
anyone. Um, can I show the Can you show
the call for narrow down categories
again?
Yeah, it's really right here. What I'm
doing is my system I think he's like
where where are you calling it? Oh,
right here. I'm just saying it's like
the the union of the tool options are
the unions of all the
tools narrow down to some
amount and we'll post all this code
online. So like you'll get access to it.
We'll send the getter rebound
everything so you'll be able to run this
yourself. I'll probably disable the
embedding thing or maybe what I'll do is
I'll just save the embeddings to disk so
you don't have to recomputee it uh
unless you change the raw
string. Um cool. Or you could just test
this with a slice, right? You know, go
edit the JSON file or just slice out the
first 50 and test this. Um, maybe I'll
do that
because I suspect that's what's
happening right now.
Oh, he gave up.
I have no idea how far in I got. There's
50 cents of open AI credits down the
drain.
Okay, this might be faster. Doing a
thousand network calls. Um, I realized
10,000 was probably too ambitious. Um,
I'm going to do less. I'm gonna do 100.
Um, I'm going to only select the top
like the 10
matches. This will likely be a lot
faster. Um, and really what I should
have done is hosted a local embedding
model and just run that. And now you can
see exactly what happened. So I said
what? And this is kind of cool. I said
database stuff and it started building
Superbase into my tooling system.
Right. And actually it said notion API
get page which is probably right. It
picked the superbase MCP server uh
restore page database create a new
database archive page and everything
else. You can see that some of these are
totally
wrong. Um but we can go do this. Um and
it actually asked me a really useful
question. Yes. But I want you to
navigate the
browser to
then find the database ID. And now
hopefully it'll come up with browser use
in the prompt when it does this. And
that's exactly what it just picked one.
Yep. Right. Not only did it do that,
actually list it out and picked browser
base as a thing. Can we can we see the
list of tools that made it in like the
top the top 10, top K or whatever? Yeah,
there you go. and it was able to go pick
that through because I'm only passing
the last message and it basically just
works. I think that's the whole point of
these systems. Um, but if they didn't
work, then what I would do is I'd likely
like likely have to somehow modify the
object that I'm embedding in some way so
the right thing did get selected. That
I'm I'm glad I ran that with a shorter
tool because then we actually got to see
it working into I think that was a great
call. Um, sick. But the principles are
all the same.
Cool. All right, folks. Thanks so much
for coming by.
Thanks for coming, everyone. Uh, we'll
see you guys next week. Human in the
loop. We're going to do async. We're
going to do we're going to do autonomous
agents. We're going to do clarifying
with the human for a while. I'm really
excited to show some human in the loop
code.
Awesome. Thanks everyone. Bye folks.
Good luck. Good luck.